is
[Laughter]
well uh
i guess i'm not surprised that biden
doesn't remember me
i guess the question is is what else has
he forgotten
biden's forgotten about the crisis at
our southern border i can tell you that
biden has forgotten about the inflation
that's biting the budgets of families
all throughout our country
biden has forgotten about the
demonstrators who were fighting for
freedom down in cuba and biden's even
forgotten about the constitution itself
as we saw with what he did with this
moratorium and i can just tell you i'm
the governor who
protects parents in their ability to
make the right choices for their kids
education i'm the governor who protects
the jobs and education and businesses in
florida by not letting the federal
government lock us down i'm the governor
who answers to the people of florida
not to bureaucrats in washington
how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message for
today march 23rd
2022
and yeah that's right that is my
governor ron desantis right here in the
great
the free
and the flourishing state of florida and
the elderly gentleman that we played
before him uh that's joe biden the man
pretending to be president in the united
states doesn't know who ron desantis is
which it's either a joke or he honestly
doesn't
the choice is yours uh and desantis just
smacked him down so what we are gonna do
with the show today
is a real compare and contrast of what
we've done for the first two days
this week where on monday and tuesday
this week i think i did a pretty
freaking good case if i can pat myself
on the back for just a moment of how
obvious it has become that the democrats
and the powers that be and their allies
in the media and in big tech are
honestly trying to destroy the united
states of america we went through all
the policies whether it's policing or
immigration or the economy culturally
all of the stuff that's what we laid out
for these first two days this week and
today we're going to contrast that with
what's going on right here in florida
because in florida
we are standing up for america we're
standing up for freedom and for liberty
and it's being led
by that guy right there because you know
what i always say to you guys is we just
need hope america is an idea and it's an
idea based on hope right hope that
people can live freely it's not it's not
just the default position that people
will live free there's a lot of bad
people out there there's a lot of bad
ideas out there human history is
littered
with authoritarian leaders who crush
down on people who want to live freely
and want to use their minds and flourish
and live the way they want to live right
and we're seeing that all over the world
right now right
joe biden yesterday the clip we started
the show with yesterday he's ushering in
a new world order and he hopes that
america will lead it
we'll see about that i mean i have i
have a small feeling that china has
another idea on that one um
i don't want the new world order what i
want is freedom and what i want is
happening right here in florida and
we're going to lay out a freaking case
today i've been a prosecutor all week i
was i was prosecuting joe biden uh for
the first two days this week well uh now
we're going to do a little defense he
doesn't need my defense actually but
it's going to be a defense of ron
desantis and really
a model of how you
do it right which is a fine segue to
remind you that the don't burn this
country book tour is coming and the
first three stops are right here
in florida yeah that's right we're going
to be in orlando on april 18th special
guest announced soon april 19th in west
palm beach special guest announced soon
clearwater florida on april 20th with
benny johnson uh april 21st in raleigh
north carolina with andrew clavin from
the daily wire april 22nd with the willy
wonka of politics michael malus april
23rd in chicago guest announced soon
april 24th in dallas texas with my man
glenn beck
april 25th in washington d.c we're going
to the swamp with megan mccain april 26
in west niagara new york with megyn
kelly may 11th brea california with
dennis prager may 12th oxnard california
with larry elder may 15th san jose
california guest announced soon may 16th
phoenix arizona with the next senator
from the great state of arizona blake
masters and may 18th denver colorado
guest announced soon you can get your
tickets and the vip tickets are all
going real fast uh so you may want to
jump on that davereuben.com
events and uh as i said i am going to be
laying out a case
i've got paper in front of me okay we
printed words on paper okay i've got a
sharpie it's a big show people uh we're
going to be laying out a case that
freedom can be fought for and there's a
way to do it and this is the home of
freedom and you just need good people to
stand up real quick before we get to
that i want to talk to you guys about
cozy earth you know if you appreciate
the softness and comfort of truly luxury
bedding you're gonna love today's
sponsor cozy earth i seriously seriously
love this brand cozy earth is a renowned
for offering the softest most luxurious
environmentally friendly and ethically
produced bedding today so it's not
surprising that cozy earth has received
thousands of five star ratings like this
recent review from carol who'd ever
think a set of sheets would make a
difference in how you sleep the first
night i used the sheets i slept straight
through and every night since no more
overheating waking tossing and turning
just incredible sleep
cozy earth sheets are made from the
finest luxury materials including
soft viscous from highly sustainable
bamboo and their bedding is not only
super soft lightweight and breathable
but also temperature regulating so you
sleep at the perfect temperature year
round the sweatpants are awesome too
cozy earth even offers a hundred night
sleep trial which means you have up to a
hundred nights to sleep on it wash it
and try it out
if you're not completely in love just
send it back for a full refund and for a
limited time you can save 35 on cozy
earth just go to cosyears.com dave and
enter dave at checkout to save 35 right
now that's cozyearth.com dave and be
sure to enter dave at checkout for 35
off and now back to me okay
for two days i have laid out the case
that joe biden and the democrats want to
destroy america
they either want to destroy america and
that is the goal or these are the most
inept
buffoons in the history of government
and i don't just mean american
government i mean any government of all
time anywhere
on earth
everything that they are doing is
destroying america economically
culturally
philosophically everything everything
that they are doing just look you don't
you don't even need me to tell you
look at the price of goods
look at the supply chain
look at foreign policy
gas the whole thing you guys all get it
but it's being done right here in
florida and this is what i want to
reverberate throughout the country that
there is a way to do it right and ron
desantis is the guy who's doing it right
so first off we did a whole bunch over
the last two weeks on
bill florida bill
hb1557 which the media
repeatedly was calling the don't pay gay
bill even though the word gay is not in
the bill and it had nothing to do with
homophobia or discrimination in essence
as you guys know the bill was about not
allowing teachers
meaning government employees to talk to
kindergartners through third grade about
gender identity or sexuality which is
not something that anyone other than a
parent should be talking to a kid about
especially at that age and kids
certainly aren't thinking of those
things at that age but the media went
bananas ron desantis is a homophobe
florida's gonna hunt down the gays all
the usual nonsense uh well
ron desantis is just fighting back he's
just fighting back clip one
and so i would just tell people it's a
free country do what you believe in but
understand if you are out protesting
this bill you are by definition putting
yourself in favor of injecting sexual
instruction to five six and seven year
old kids i think most people think
that's wrong i think parents especially
think that's wrong
yes most people do think it's wrong and
although the amorphous mob runs through
twitter and the blue check
whack-a-doodles and you know journalists
whatever you want to call them are all
calling him a homophobe and saying this
is backwards we all know
everyone knows you don't want anyone why
would you want a state employee or
anyone other than a parent discussing
with a six-year-old a first grader
gender identity
and then being able to hide that from
the parent the bill actually is mostly
about transparency that you wouldn't
hide things from parents that parents
have a right to know what's going on in
school
so he's pushing back and and not only is
he pushing back but then he had a sit
down with the ceo of disney and
basically told the disney guy to to take
a walk which is not an easy thing for a
governor of florida to do because you
know disney is here in orlando a lot of
employees and everything else but as
desantis pointed out you know i'm pretty
sure that a lot of the people who bring
the kids to disney are parents and uh
you may be careful you may be playing
with fire here and now disney has a
whole in essence they have a [ __ ] storm
on their hands because you've got the
ceo
sort of saying uh we don't know what to
do we're going to pull money out of
florida and the employees are staying
you're still not pro gay enough
for us or whatever it is
but desantis is continuing because you
know the other story this week is that
there was this big women's 500 yard
freestyle swimming championship
and it was one
it was won by a biological male by the
name of leah thomas
okay this is someone who was something
like 450th in men's swimming who decided
to transition and
you know my position on this if an adult
wants to do anything with their life
live how they wish change their name
wear whatever they want that's fine once
you're an adult it's a different thing
when you're a kid but in essence leah
thomas is a biological male
with biological male genitals i will
leave it at that the girls are now
seeing that in the locker room who won
first place but desantis he ain't
putting up with that either
if you look at what the ncaa has done
by allowing
basically men to compete in women's
athletics in this case the swimming you
had the number one woman who finished
was from sarasota
eminent she won the silver medal she's
been an absolute superstar her whole
career and she had the fastest time
of any woman in college athletics now
the ncaa
is basically taking efforts to destroy
women's athletics they're trying to
undermine the integrity of the
competition and they're crowning
somebody else uh the woman's champion
and we think that's wrong and so in
florida i'm going to be uh later
as this is a floridian who i think
deserves to be recognized you know we're
going to be doing a proclamation
saying uh that emma
is the best female swimmer in the 500
meter freestyle because she earned that
and we need to stop allowing
organizations like the ncaa to
perpetuate frauds on the public and
that's exactly what they're doing they
are putting ideology ahead of
opportunity for women out
guys what do i say every single day now
when someone's telling the truth you
know they're telling the truth and
because we live in such a time of lies
it's actually
a
it's a relief it's a release off your
chest isn't it when you hear someone
tell the truth and say the thing that we
all know that is obvious even though
most people won't say it and not only is
he saying it he is a man of his word
because he did release the proclamation
and good for emma good for emma emma if
you're watching you are the best 500
swimmer in in the state of florida maybe
in the country i don't know you want to
come on the show we'll talk about it
i'll what can i do for you i'd love to
help you out here's an image in case
you're just unsure of this story i know
it's been getting a lot of coverage but
first here's an image after the race so
that's leah thomas on the left that's
emma's was it watson was it emma watson
no not watson
um
emma wyant sorry emma wine emma watson
is in uh harry potter or something
different emma uh but okay so there's
leah thomas the supposed winner women's
winner of this thing
uh and there's of course uh emma in the
middle there's the third place finisher
on the right do you see do you think
maybe there's a biological problem am i
a bigot or a racist or a nazi for saying
that maybe there's a biological problem
and if you want to see how this is all
connected to the media and how they lie
about everything and push a narrative
nbc news covered this story and look at
the image that they put up this is
actually this is really really
extraordinary we're going to get it in
just a second i think we've got it these
are the same people who are constantly
constantly telling you that everything
people are exactly the same the image on
the left right there is the image that
nbc news used on their report you can
see it is heavily airbrushed to take
away a lot of the male features the
strong features of the nose and the eyes
and the mouth i mean look what they did
there that looks like it's instagram
airbrushed which girls use on instagram
to usually make their eyes look bigger
and their skin softer and everything
else the image on the right is the
unedited image so nbc news ran this
story and decided for the narrative of
the story we are going to make
the guy
the woman with the penis who won first
place we are going to make he or she
whatever you want to say uh in this case
i'm going to say he and if they're going
to boot me off youtube it's ridiculous
but a guy should not be winning a
woman's uh a woman's swimming race it's
just as simple as that and that has
nothing to do with bigotry and hatred
and you all know it including you you
weirdo youtube sensors who are watching
this right now just waiting and you
freaks of media matters one more time
put it up on the image one more time so
just know that that nbc put that image
up on the left if they were honest if
mvc was honest if journalists were
honest would they be airbrushing the
image to make him look more like a her
i think not but actually if you do want
to take care of your skin this is my
greatest segue ever
i want to talk to you guys about shamany
you know if you have red inflamed
blotchy uneven skin tone leah thomas has
some of that actually it can be a
struggle for all of us and what about
fine lines forehead wrinkles and under
eye puffiness oh yeah thomas has some of
that the only solution has been abrasive
irritating products with retinol until
now thanks to geniusel's new ultra
retinol cream see all of the skin
healing benefits of retinol and the
hydrating effects of hyaluronic acid
without harsh irritation we should do it
before and after of leah right here
genius cells retinol alternative cream
uses clinical concentrations of natural
of a natural alternative to correct red
inflamed skin visibly reduce wrinkles
and even out skin tone made for
sensitive skin it's effective hydration
for all skin types and perfect for both
men and women this incredibly powerful
anti-wrinkle treatment is packed with a
blend of natural ingredients that gives
your skin all the benefits of retinol
without any of the unwanted irritation
go to genusell.com
dave right now for up to 50 off the
brand new ultra retinol cream you will
be amazed with the results or your money
back you'll also get genucles immediate
effects for results in 12 hours or less
free with your order that's an eighty
nine dollar value go to januselle.com
dave that's g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com
slash dave free express shipping free
returns exquisite customer service
genusell.com dave genyasel.com dave and
now back to me okay
you see what i'm doing on the show today
people because you're a wise audience
you guys are like the reverse msnbc
people there are people right now
watching msnbc getting dumber there are
people right now watching the view
right with those insane harpies and
they're becoming dumber and more racist
actually right now you're watching this
and we're all learning a little
something and we're doing it together
well you know what not only has rhonda
ron desantis defended schools
and teachers and parents he's defending
teachers honestly too because the
teachers are being indoctrinated by the
administrations and by other teachers
and everything else so he's defending
schools he's defending parents he's
defending young girls when it comes to
uh swimming and athletics and everything
else uh but now let's back up to some of
the other things that he's done over the
last two years okay because he's done an
awful lot while we have watched uh most
of our blue states and specifically the
blue cities i mean new york san
francisco seattle portland you guys know
all the drill while we watch them be
destroyed during blm riots and through
antifa activities and everything else
ron desantis decided to fund the police
here in florida and not just fund them
but fund them and then some
i asked the legislature in this
legislative session we need to do
bonuses
for law enforcement someone to fund
some want to defund the police
we're funding the police and then some
and then some yeah so you know what's
happening right now there are police
officers literally from all over the
country good decent hard-working police
officers who just want to uphold the law
they are moving to florida right now and
that will make florida safer and it will
make the other places less safe because
here if you're a police officer you're
going to be respected by the
administration by your citizens and
everything else so he did the reverse of
what the machine told him to do right
and then what has happened subsequently
as these cities and states have crumbled
and you see all the videos we've shown
you all the videos of all the crime and
all over all over the uh the cities and
the states i actually saw one in beverly
hills los angeles yesterday with a bunch
of guys that just break into a jewelry
store broad daylight broad daylight tons
of people on the street they break in
grab a whole bunch of stuff they stole
three to five million dollars worth of
jewelry in the middle of the day they
have not been caught as of last i heard
a few minutes before we started this
thing uh so here in florida we will have
a well-funded uh slick operation and i
have a lot of friends that are in the
nypd from my old new york days and and
through some other connections they've
had it they've had it i mean they really
hated bill de blasio and they are not
loving this eric adams guy and it's like
hey come on down to florida and uh ron
desantis will find a job for you and
you'll be paid better and treated better
and everything else okay so we went
after biden and the administration on
policing i just compared that with what
desantis is doing here but it's not just
that on the border crisis
uh
you know what's happening you know
what's happening in texas we showed you
video they're just people are just
walking over it is worse than it has
ever been well desantis uh is going to
make sure that we take care of our
border here in florida there was a
letter that was recently sent by the
governors of texas and arizona
seeking mutual aid which we
do all the time in inches of emergency
these states have sent florida support
when we've responded to emergencies here
in our state and they wanted
support
so that they could do
what the federal government is either
unwilling or unable to do
secure the border and protect the people
not just of their states but of the
entire country because of the nationwide
impact that has and so today
we're here to announce that the state of
florida is answering the call
florida is going to support texas and
arizona we believe that securing the
southern border is important for our
country
but specifically we believe it will
benefit the people of florida to be able
to get this under control and so where
the federal government has failed the
states are stepping up
i think how extraordinary that is right
florida
is mostly surrounded by water we're a
big peninsula you've seen the map right
yet he is helping these other states
that need help because the federal
government is in complete dereliction of
their duty but i would even say it's
worse than that they are intentionally
trying to collapse our system that is
what i have come to that is the
conclusion and there's a beauty in what
he also said there which is that the
states will do what the federal
government won't that is what
the original founding documents were set
up to do federalism the states are
supposed to do most of the stuff and if
that has ever become more clear i mean
it has never been more clear than it is
right now here's a beautiful moment so
you know they they send all these
immigrants in through texas but then
once they get through texas you know
then they start bouncing through all
these other states and then you don't
know where they're settled you don't
know if they have coveted while we're
locking down our people with covet but
you don't have to come in with a mask
they come in through mexico but are they
haitians or from the middle east or
whatever
and by the way nothing that i'm
discussing right now and nothing that
ron de santa said had anything to do
with bigotry or racism or anything else
a country either has borders or not you
either have laws you don't this is basic
simple stuff there used to be an orange
man who said that i forget what happened
to him um but here is what desantis
said we will do if they send illegal
immigrants here to florida if they're
going to come here you know we'll
provide buses and provide them
i will send them to delaware and do that
i mean if he's not going to support the
border being secured then then he should
be able to have everyone there so we
will do whatever we can in that regard
and we are absolutely gonna do
everything we can
i mean how freaking great send them to
delaware get the buses send them to
biden's house i'm not kidding just send
them to biden's house in delaware let
let them be in delaware and hang out
there but they can't be here and that
has nothing to do with racism or
anything else i live in south florida i
live in the miami area
you hang out with 10 people you're going
to hear 87 languages okay that is the
beauty of this place and by the way many
of the people that live here are
venezuelan and cuban uh they often come
from places where communism and
socialism and collectivism was tried and
they are the most freedom loving people
you will ever meet uh so i love this
idea uh send them to delaware we need to
clone desantis that really is where
we're at where are we at with human
cloning can you guys google that for me
i know we can clone dogs now or we when
we did dolly
yeah we're oh they might be doing it in
china okay
we need to clone the guy all right so
let's move on so now we're talking about
uh the border as well and you can see
that there's a stark difference between
the biden administration and uh what
desantis is doing here related to the
border and how he's actually helping
other states concerning the border
but also we're having some economic
problems have you heard about that have
you tried to get gas recently have you
noticed about inflation are you trying
to build a house or get any raw
materials and two by fours cost 10 times
what they did literally a year and a
half ago well desantis is also trying to
figure out well how can we protect
ourselves while the federal government
does all sorts of crazy things
related to inflation and now the biden
administration is talking about a
digital dollar which kind of sounds cool
because that has something to do with
crypto and bitcoin or something but uh
desantis can see through the curtain
and there's a difference between a
decentralized digital currency
cryptocurrency like a bitcoin and what
some are talking about doing
at the federal level to convert u.s
dollars into basically a digital
currency i think there's a lot of
hazards with that when that's centrally
controlled i worry about the amount of
power that that would give
someone an essential authority to
basically be able to shut off access to
purchasing certain goods you know we'd
be in unchartered territories and we've
seen how some of these financial
institutions acting at the behest of
government can cut people off can you
imagine
if the federal government actually
controlled whether you could even go in
so i know biden issued an executive
order i'm very concerned about that but
i think it's something that we need to
be watching
it's the fundamental difference between
decentralization and centralization what
what the left seems to want what the
communists i mean there's just no point
calling them anything else the democrats
they're democrats i don't know what
makes them democrats anymore with the
democrats socialists whatever they are
what they want is a centralized system
because in a centralized system somebody
makes the decision and they're above you
they're the elites they're above you and
they tell you how to live
what freedom loving people want is
exactly what rhonda santa said right
there which is you want a decentralized
system because that's bottom up that
allows people to exchange good goods and
services with each other hopefully for
the benefit of both and from that you
can build not only it starts with
individuals but then you can hopefully
build families and communities and all
of those things and then states and
everything else so when biden says that
we want perhaps in the united states a
digital dollar it sort of sounds right
it's like oh well there's something
about bitcoin and crypto and digital
dollar it sounds right
but as desantis correctly points out if
it's centralized that means they can
just cut you off at any moment that
means they can shut down your wallet at
any moment remember what happened in
canada a few weeks ago when they were
going after
the the bank accounts of the truckers
think how dangerous it would be if we
have a digital dollar and then you
protest the government and then all the
government has to do some some
government lackey bureaucrat
adios amigo your money is gone and guess
what it's going to get funneled back
into the system and we're all going to
get a cut the big guy does get his 10
percent you know what i'm saying so you
got to be really really careful of this
and i i suspect that florida will
continue to figure out new innovative
ways to work on the crypto side i mean
we know that gov mayor suarez down here
in miami i mean he's leading a
revolution
an actual revolution a digital
revolution is happening right here in
miami it's awesome it's why we moved
locals down here and and rumble moved to
sarasota and uh it's a beautiful thing
um but the other part of all of the
economic mess that we have right now is
that the price of gas is bananas it's
completely insane i was in la early last
week it was 750 for regular unleaded we
showed you the picture a couple days ago
about diesel somewhere in california now
9.99 a gallon again this isn't the type
of thing you need me to explain to you
just go to your local gas station is gas
much higher or not and by the way it was
going way higher before
the russia thing so everyone keeps
saying oh no no this is russia's fault
as if we have no our administration has
no control over our economy whatsoever
it's all russia russia can do whatever
they want to us whenever they want just
simply untrue uh but
you know biden says that no matter how
much money we pour into the economy it
doesn't affect inflation and you know
there's not much we can do about gas
prices and everyone should get a tesla
well he doesn't want you to get a tesla
actually because he doesn't like a lot
of musk he wants you to get like a gm
electric car even though the gm vault
remember the gm vaulted the government
poured
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars to it failed it doesn't they
don't produce those cars anymore
but
ron desantis is taking the opposite
approach he is actually trying to give
people a tax holiday he is saying we
don't want your money as citizens you
guys are struggling because of the
idiotic policies of the federal
government well we're going to give you
an actual tax holiday to aleve some of
the pain
inflation is an invisible tax on
floridians it represents a pay cut for
individuals and for families alike and
one of the ways families have felt the
pinch has been in significantly higher
gas prices
to help alleviate this burden for
florida families i'm proposing a 1
billion gas tax holiday to help reduce
prices at the pump if washington dc
won't change course then we have a
responsibility to step up on behalf of
our floridians
[Applause]
that's the governor that's a chief
executive of the state president
you're a buffoon your policies are
ridiculous i'm going to do what i can
for my people okay so let's continue
we've been laying out a case here so you
we've compared and contrast biden on
schools on gender on border on the
economy but it's not just that it's also
even foreign policy now the governor of
a state shouldn't have that much to do
with foreign policy right he is the
chief executive of a state his job is to
make sure that whatever state he's in
charge of is going right in that state
you can chime in occasionally about
foreign policy obviously you have a free
speech you can say whatever you want but
technically you shouldn't have to say
that much about foreign policy but we
are now living in a time where it is
very obvious that our administration not
only is screwing everything up again
either intentionally or not
everyone can make their own judgment
call on that um but that nothing that
they say is true so it's impossible to
have any moral clarity uh even in a case
when a country like russia invades
another sovereign nation like ukraine so
we just get these muddled these
ridiculously muddled messages from the
administration and you know we're not
going to war we're not going to make
this thing world war iii but we're going
to fund those guys and we're going to
give them weapons and maybe we're going
to talk about no-fly zone and we're
going to do all the sanctions stuff and
everything else yadda yadda uh but how
about some clarity on uh the putin guy
ron desantis ladies and gentlemen
this is a guy who's basically an
authoritarian gas station attendant okay
with some legacy nuclear weapons from
the old soviet union they their whole
society is hollowed out except for that
energy and so if you want to hit him hit
him at the gas pump hit him hit him with
energy
yeah you hit him with energy maybe say
if you were president the first thing
that you don't do
when you're sworn in is cancel the
keystone xl pipeline and the 800 000
barrels of oil that we could have been
getting a day
from western canada yes i know some of
the oil still comes through and it comes
through trains and everything else but
the point is we had opportunities to
open this pipeline it was going to
happen it was happening under trump
we showed you video a week or two ago of
the premiere of alberta canada talking
about how what a great opportunity it
could have been and that they've got
excess energy and it would have created
i think 10 000 canadian jobs on top of
everything else
so yes some energy independence might be
good but it's not really the route that
the democrats want to go because you
know they've got aoc's green new deal
from that woman um
okay so you see the case we're laying
out the case now i just threw in some
stuff about energy and gas and we talked
about gender and we talked about
schooling and we talked about borders
but now let's move on to uh covet you
may remember kovid do you guys remember
kovid you guys
he doesn't remember covet does that
doesn't no nobody in this room remembers
but there alright so there was a thing a
while back kovid where suddenly they
wanted us to wrap our faces and things
and hide from people and stay away from
people and stay at a bunker and not go
to work you were allowed to go out if
you wanted to destroy businesses it was
it was a real messy time i don't know
we'll do more on it soon um but not
everyone went completely insane during
covid uh florida didn't go completely
insane and uh this ron desantis guy who
i've been talking about on today's show
he fought the power he fought the power
that was demanding everyone close up
everyone mask up everyone be forced to
be vaccinated
and a whole bunch more
here he is railing against the cdc and
biden
because they're suddenly doing
everything that ron's been doing for the
last two years these kids are so much
happier being able to go to school
without having to wear masks for eight
hours a day so when you start to see
them kind of re-evaluate or say all this
just understand this the science didn't
change well the medical science didn't
change
the political science change they feel
the heat they know that voters have been
tired of perpetual lockdown policies
they know that they have basically
offered no off ramp and and they know
that they're fixing to get whooped at
the polls and so that's what's causing
the epiphany but the fact of the matter
is if they had looked at the actual
science from the beginning
they would have known that this was
something that florida was right on
yeah and we've shown you plenty of
videos of our surgeon general here in
florida latipo who is not only a great
guy who uh desantis hired in the midst
of all of this um but he happens to be a
youngish black man and if he was a lefty
he'd be on the cover of newsweek and
time magazine and everywhere else
but because he's a scary right winger
because you know these right-wingers
always demanding freedom and letting you
live freely uh you probably don't know
who he is although we talk about him
here but that line the medical science
didn't change the political science
changed because they're now just doing
all of the stuff
that ron desantis was doing the entire
time and in case it's not clear guys as
a
new floridian someone that's been here
for what two and a half three months at
this point i live in a different country
than when i lived in dystopian
california and you know what i just
mentioned dystopian california i haven't
put any money in the jar lately this is
the escape cali fund i will be giving a
couple thousand bucks to somebody who
wants to leave california at the end of
the year and move to florida i'm going
to put in 10 for this you know i feel
good and i'm going to throw in a bunch
of extra money at the end of the year
and someone i want you to escape and i
want you to bring your family and your
resources and everything else down to
florida and help us build a great state
which we we've already got a great state
but i want you to help keep it great um
desantis also has called out the the
ridiculous hypocritical politicians of
the last two years because all of these
absolutely clownish buffoons aoc
partying in miami beach
right but if you make fun of her for
parting mammy beat she says just because
you want to have sex with her uh aoc i
do want to be clear about something i do
not and i i repeat i do not want to have
sex with you okay it's very important
you understand that i do not there's the
clip for today's show okay i do not want
to have sex with aoc
uh but a bunch of them right eric
swalwell was down here gretchen whitmer
was down here these people were locking
down their own constituents while they
partied in florida the place that they
were saying was run by a bigot and a
nazi and a right-wing maniac and all of
that stuff and then they came down here
to be unmasked um aoc probably the worst
of all of them because she went to a bar
it happened to have been a drag bar in
in miami beach and she's got just tons
of people around her and they're fawning
over her like the golden calf it's
really disgusting and she literally had
kids locked down and still in masks in
new york while she did it well desantis
ain't taking it from these people either
big city mayors and i'll tell you and
anchor some of these uh leftist tv hosts
who constantly criticize water mandate
mass walk down all this stuff then they
end up on the beach somewhere in south
florida i'll tell you one of the things
i'm proud though is like our floridians
they give these people hell when they
see them down here because they're
they're proud of our freedom and they
know these people have been bad-mouthing
that the cherry on the sunday was when
you had over new year's you had aoc
coming down criticizing florida then
comes down so we decided to make uh kind
of a little joke about it so we created
t-shirts that said escape to florida the
lockdown liberal tour and instead of
having concert dates on the back we had
governor whitmer march of 2021 aoc and
the dates they were all in florida
and we sold more outside the state than
we sold here because people realize how
hypocritical these people are
this is how you win you guys get it and
it's not about winning for winning sake
it's winning for freedom's sake it's
winning to save freaking america which
is hanging on by a thread but we can do
it and and everyone watching this
whatever state you're in get this video
your governor so they get some balls
here's ron desantis just kind of
recapping the whole thing so this is
video from a couple months ago
but he's just recapping like a whole
bunch of stuff that that biden has done
wrong about everything afghanistan
border masking kids and a whole bunch
more not only that he was on vacation
they had to ply him off a vacation to
give a kind of a half [ __ ] statement on
camera that he said wasn't taking
questions then he goes back on vacation
and he is obsessed while you have all
the stuff going on with afghanistan
obviously all the stuff at the southern
border which you and i have talked about
one of the biggest border disasters in
the history of our country inflation gas
prices and what does he do he is
obsessed with having the government
force kindergartners to wear mass all
day in school in florida we believe that
that's the parents decision joe biden
thinks the federal government should
come in and overrule the parents and
force these young kids to wear these
masks and you gotta wonder where are
your priorities that you're so obsessed
with this issue and so obsessed with
taking away parents rights and you're
letting afghanistan burn our border burn
and so many other things in our country
fall to pieces
all right so that was desantis months
ago just kind of recapping a bunch of
the things that i've talked about here
but you know as i lay out this case
as the prosecutor of the biden
administration and and the defense
attorney let's say for rhonda santos
even though he doesn't need my defense
the guy's defending himself and he's
doing it right he's incredible staff
behind him that they're just doing it
right the messaging is right they're
hitting they're on the attack they take
no [ __ ] from the media all of that
stuff but as i lay out this case i am
also acting here as the judge and a
judge would say well i'd like to see all
the information you know what i mean
this is maybe it seemed a little slanted
almost you know what do you you don't
like biden you play all these clips of
of desantis you don't like biden give me
a biden clip so that it'll even this
freaking thing out biden must be a good
guy biden must really care about america
and not sort of handing over america's
power biden wouldn't want to usher in
some sort of weird thing say like a new
world order thing that's crazy talk
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and uh since then we established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've gotta unite the rest
of the free world and doing it
all right the choice is yours
the choice is yours america not just
florida the choice is yours america
you can either elect leaders
who will defend the way of life we have
come to know the way of life that all of
our
parents and grandparents and
great-grandparents and in many cases
even before that came to this place to
build our letter a better life
and they freaking did it
and we're giving it away
so you can either follow joe biden down
through
his new world order
and when i say joe biden you're not
really following joe biden you're you're
following whoever's in charge of joe
biden or
you can follow the other guy that i
talked about here we've got a great cold
close for you today because uh the
hearing
for the new supreme court justice
catanji brown jackson is happening and
there was just an extraordinary moment
that we're going to tease here at the
end of the show today and then we'll do
a full coverage on that
tomorrow and she's sort of the perfect
she's the perfect bite nominee but i
want to get to a couple of locals
comments real quick uh amy says the
amazing governor desantis just signed a
law for a financial literacy requirement
for high school graduates i know i saw
it a minute before we started the show
which is why we didn't cover it i am
sure we will be told it's racist i mean
for sure for sure we will be told it's
racist if you say that high school
graduates have to have the basic
understanding of economics so that they
can go out into the world you will be
called racist but
we will continue and he will go on i
know it's just more goodness it's more
goodness
dragonhawk says i still say
that the female swimmers need to all
refuse to race a biological male they
have to stop expecting everyone else to
fix it for them that's a really
interesting
concept and it's very in line with the
things that i believe like you must
fight for yourself you cannot expect if
you're a young female swimmer you cannot
expect that the system will magically
correct itself for you yes ron desantis
did the right thing and we he signed
this proclamation uh so that emma is the
winner in effect of the 500 um but that
that that's one piece of the fight the
other piece of the fight is what you can
do whether you're a swimmer or the
parent of a swimmer or you're a swimming
coach everyone knows this is wrong and
we're all afraid of something that we're
not sure what it is what are we really
afraid of here are we really afraid that
if you say the truth
that men and women are different it's
just how it is right it's just what
biology and evolution has has rung for
hundreds and hundreds and thousands of
years and millions of years
they're different men had to go out and
kill to bring the food home and the
women usually were home taking care of
the kids and that's just fine and yet
there are margins on both sides where
sometimes you have men who are more
caregivers and women who want to be out
there more but there still are
fundamental differences which is why
leah thomas was
450th or so when when she was a man or
man
jeff says
stark difference between biden
administration and any semblance of
reality yeah maybe i'll just start
calling the desantis administration the
reality administration it's just like
reality here in florida it's just
reality and reality is better than
whatever this fake nonsensical bs that
they're putting us through
is uh is going and happening right now
guys quick reminder before the cold
close dave rubin.com events you can join
me on tour dennis prager will be joining
me megan kelly blake masters megan
mccain glenn beck larry elder benny
johnson michael malus andrew clavin we
got a couple other big names coming it's
just going to be awesome we're opening
this thing in orlando i wanted to do the
first couple shows right here in florida
honestly i there was a point where i was
telling my whole team i only won a tour
in florida and i was they said no no
you must get out there um but we're
gonna add a bunch more dates i know a
lot of people are asking about nashville
specifically we just couldn't work it on
this first leg uh but the book is out on
april 12th the tour begins april 18th
right here in florida in orlando in in
disney's shadow
we will be in disney's shadow but we're
gonna do it uh if you want to play along
during the show for the live chat you
can uh join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with uh judge andrew
napolitano is up on youtube and rumble
right now and the full things up
absolutely ad free
at uh at locals and our cold clothes
ladies and gentlemen which i think sort
of fits perfectly with everything we've
done today
so you have a good one and we'll be back
tomorrow
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
senator in my work as a judge what i do
is i
address disputes if there's a dispute
about a definition people make arguments
and i look at the law and i decide so
i'm not
the fact that you
can't give me a straight answer about
something as fundamental as what a woman
is underscores the dangers of the kind
of progressive education
that we are hearing about